[Musique]
des tons après votre naissance à
toufflers et à toi ton père et moi avons
divorcé
chacun bien fiscaux des levées de son
côté est évidemment j'ai eu la mauvaise
pioche
je freine djougou
[Musique]
enfin je perds ma connaissance aucun
calicot l'onu de voir si mal à l'aise
comment ça se passe pour toi au niveau
carrière
génial savait laissait le méchant le
plus recherché c'est ça qui fait virer
carrément génial ça défile
je t'ai fait venir pour reprendre
l'entreprise familiale
tu m'as la méchanceté dans le sang c'est
derrière moi tout ça je comprends qu'on
peut servir ce truc
olaf h bien méchant
pas mal du tout
[Musique]
alors vous avez c'est quoi aujourd'hui
accroche toi là
lien
au revoir
[Musique]
ce à quoi les filles du diable
mais un nouveau procès
[Musique]
ça fait longtemps qu'on attend une fois
j'en ai vu une ils décident tous j'ai
cru que j'allais mourir
[Musique]
alors vous êtes des méchants maintenant
et à vider
[Musique]